françois-xavier bellamy je suis
professeur de philosophie je suis élu
depuis dix ans dans ma ville à
versailles je vais emmener avec vous
tous cette liste pour les élections
européennes
l'europe et la france sont à un tournant
de leur histoire
aujourd'hui nous le voyons bien nos
sociétés traverse une crise profonde
parce que nous avons le sentiment
angoissant de ne plus pouvoir maîtriser
notre destin
l'europe a inventé la démocratie
c'est-à-dire notre capacité de décider
ensemble de l'avenir que nous voulons
dans le monde qui se dessine
cette capacité de maîtriser notre destin
est de plus en plus incertaine et nous
avons besoin de l'europe de la
construction européenne pour pouvoir
agir ensemble d'une manière plus
efficace
mais pour sauver l'europe encore faut-il
la changer en profondeur pour qu'elle
fasse la preuve de son efficacité et qu
ainsi elle se réconcilie avec les
peuples européens
c'est le projet que nous allons partager
ensemble c'est le défi qui est devant
nous et ce défi est décisif pour y
parvenir
j'ai besoin de chacun d'entre vous aucun
candidat ne pourra réussir seul et notre
équipe qui va se constituer de
compétences multiples aura aussi besoin
de votre soutien de votre enthousiasme
de votre adhésion de vos idées de votre
énergie pour aller convaincre par tous
qui lie à une autre voie pour l'europe
que celle d'un affrontement stérile
entre ceux qui veulent la déconstruire
et ceux qui veulent persévérer dans la
voie d'un déni qui a fait la preuve de
son inefficacité
nous avons devant nous quatre mois pour
convaincre et je compte sur vous